Fiona yes amazing amazing thank you okay
Jody she's on fleek oh yeah Sandra
you're giving me a whole vibrator a
whole thing I feel like you guys are
like the ultimate like new girl group
yeah absolutely
I just need a name yeah killing Eve
sings I love it I love it so season 1
was amazing
I totally binge-watched it and fans are
obsessed with the show similar to the
obsessions that you know the characters
have in it
what does that feel like to just see how
much people love this show just the
reception coming I think it says more
about men I think it's it's such a show
which people can invest themselves in
and go oh my god the girls are something
terrible actually I'd like to do that a
morality of that one and this one being
you know a clever disaster is just Mars
and she's so charming and everything I
mean I don't find her chummy but people
do find her Johnny
and I think that's really it's I think I
like I think it's a bit of a dialogue
with the audience they they love it it's
kind of it's also about where we are
what do you think I feel like it's it's
great to be able to experience this like
you we were at the TCA is last year and
to be able to speak to the press again
the following year and feeling all the
support and all the episode yeah you
know that is actually I will say I
probably one of the number one words
that when people come up to me and say
how much they liked this show SAS has to
obsess and that's always so exciting
that that year on you're riding the wave
of something that is resonating with
people it's it's it's you know it's it's
one of the it's one of the things that
you really hope for when you're
connecting through your work with an
audience and to have that reflected it's
fantastic yeah I was reading online
people were saying about you Jody
that your character they're so
mesmerized by the character and then
they watch your interviews or see you on
social media and they're like she is so
different just different still
mesmerizing but different and it's fact
people are fascinated by it like who you
really are averse
yeah yeah that's yeah that's that's I
mean that's a huge compliment yeah I
mean people are really confused when
they meet you yes you know I mean I bet
you they're really confused cuz it's
like you remember that one time early on
you were walking on the street in
Manhattan and you saw one of our bosses
Sarah and Sarah had this um this was
very er this is a year ago
yeah and Sarah looked at Jody and I
Sarah like I couldn't figure out kind of
what was going on
I think she was really freaked my Arioch
she was like I'm sorry mister kind of
recoiled but and yeah I think people
always think I'm gonna be awful people
you know get so close to their
characters sometimes it's hard for
people to separate you and things so
they're just so shocked that I'm not
which is the only good points out
honestly the depth of Jody's talent you
know I mean is that she's acting and
also the acting she's acting she's
acting
we couldn't cause really villanelle
because we'd all be dead all three of
you guys are so dynamic three strong
females it's so lovely to watch what can
you guys tell us about season two what
can you tease us with for through me for
Eve I think she just goes into the
darkness fully and the lines that she
crosses over just keep on getting wider
and wider she goes past her limit and I
think both of these characters are
pushing her past her limit
mm-hmm I think also as well the series
picks up like 30 seconds the way we left
off in series 1 yeah it was you were in
bad shape
yeah I mean she stopped me yeah so it
was rough enough to get over that little
bump and on your first and but I think
the stakes are really high and I think
in terms of villain now what we we tried
to explore is what is going on in her
mind
you know this kind of a constant battle
with people thinking oh she does have
some humanity and she does have morals I
think like I was which she she ribbons
that and and I think that's what we've
tried to explore a little bit more yeah
I think I try and steady the ship I
think I try and stay to the ship it has
to be studied by the end of the first
season yeah we'd be in Mars by now if
something wasn't yeah calm down for a
moment
mm-hmm what tune in next season sander
the last time I saw you was on the red
carpet with your parents I feel like
your parents are superstars they are
superstars
they've just mom and dad are superstars
love them I mean they should maybe you
know do your speeches for you at this
point just go up no no they don't no no
no no they're great parents yeah they're
not actors I can do my own speed camera
Nelson because it's also you know they
are themselves you know they're all
themselves and I think it had a lot of
meaning for other um you know people who
have parents who are immigrants to feel
that immigrant of experience to have
your imp and your parents up there and
just being themselves and fully
embodying themselves that's great I was
I was so happy that I had the
opportunity to bring them yeah and to be
embraced like you can just see people
like love them I'm like yeah like I was
like I love like they're amazing they're
really wonderful people and even in your
speeches they've been very inspiring yes
yeah you know we all come from different
backgrounds and
and it's not always the case that you
have a really good relationship with
your family and your parents but I
happen to be very very lucky that I do
have one so when I was able to say you
know III when I was able to say I love
you it was very specific and different
than thank you because I can because I
really can't say it's really true you
know so I feel like voicing that and now
in it's not like you're it's not like
you're actually saying that but there is
a there's an immigrant context to that
that has a lot of meaning that I knew in
that moment or I hoped in that moment
that was translated yeah I think it I
think it was so many secrets unfolded in
season one mm-hmm
we're hoping more you know gets revealed
in season two where will we see your
characters in the show is there anything
that you can tell us about the evolution
of you - hmm I think what a huge factor
that evolution of their relationship is
the what happened in villanelles
Apartments at the end of series one I
think action that you did has a profound
effect on villanelle what that effect is
yeah I'm not gonna say because I feel as
though it may be surprising to some of
the audience but I think that definitely
changes them both in a way that neither
of them were quite ready for yeah was
that juicy enough no I think it's like
you know the the difficulty of the
romance is how to be together mm-hmm you
know and also the difficulty of the
dynamic the impossible I should say
engines and more of the impossible
dynamic is how can you actually be
together and I think that we definitely
explore that whether that works or not
remains to be seen but again
the strong dynamics as you're saying
between these characters just continue
going further and further you know she's
a big part of it
oh yeah I think it's a bit like you know
the way in which van Gogh painted those
olive trees you kind of got an olive
tree again without thinking van Gogh but
there's something about these two have
been so well crafted and invented and
adapted by Phoebe that now you kind of
get any gesture they do without thinking
of the opposite that's interesting
that's well said yeah it's the world is
gin you cut a good end he innocently no
because of these two so I think the
audience are in on that game and they
look you might be just going down the
road like oh my god they don't know
what's gonna happen
ah and I think for us the fun certainly
when we're reading the scripts you know
is they go wrong you think oh my god I
don't think that's gonna happen even
though we're thinking fast - yeah we're
all thinking fast but never fast enough
for the series mm-hmm well said that's
why she's careless well ladies it was so
nice to me you guys all look so
beautiful the shows amazing of such a
family
you